c'est le combientième interview c'est le
4e ou 5e 5e déjà le temps passe
salut bienvenue dans ce cinquième
interview à la table aujourd'hui je veux
recevoir quelqu'un que vous pensez
peut-être pas connaître pour certains
alors que vous le connaissez tous une
manière ou d'une autre il s'agit de
navaux qui est à l'origine par exemple
de série Bref Serge Le MiTo coécrit
énormément de spectacles de gens que
vous connaissez pas que Ken Khojandi il
est il est un peu celui qui fait naître
des blagues c'est quelqu'un il en
parlera mieux tout à l'heure durant
l'interview qui aime pas en fait prendre
en main les projets qui aiment bien par
contre les accompagner à porter les
idées à porter la création créer les
blagues etc etc c'est juste passionnant
et c'est formidable qu'on est sur la
chaîne je suis très content qu'il soit
là pour ce cinquième interview à la
table juste avant que l'interview
commence j'en profite aussi pour vous
dire que mon nouveau livre est sorti mon
septième livre si vous avez aimé votre
temps est infini vous allez adorer
celui-ci votre idée va devenir une
réalité si vous pensez ne jamais avoir
le temps de faire ce que vous voulez ou
que c'est compliqué de mener à bien vos
idées que ce soit pour des trucs pro ou
des trucs perso ou des trucs créatifs
etc je pense vraiment que c'est du peu
vous aider en tout cas c'est tout ce que
j'ai mis en place pour m'aider moi parce
que je suis un gros procrastinateur mais
comme vous avez vu je fais quand même
beaucoup de choses mais parce que j'ai
trouvé une manière de faire les choses
et c'est mon expérience que je partage
dedans avec des outils vraiment
pratiques pour vous qui j'espère vous
aideront mais les disposer tous les
libraires dans les grandes surfaces
habituelles Amazon Fnac cultura je vous
mets les liens dans la description voilà
j'espère que ça vous plaira n'hésitez
pas à le feuilleter mais l'emprunter
dans une bibliothèque ou un truc comme
ça parce que je suis persuadé qu'il y a
un truc à l'intérieur qui va pouvoir
vous aider et maintenant on va écouter
bientôt tu es le cinquième Bruno je peux
t'appeler Bruno bah c'est mon nom
comment tu dis ton nom de famille moi je
dis monsieur mais peut-être je commence
mal et non car c'est mousqueux mousqueux
c'est italien ok moi je vais t'appeler
Navo pourquoi tu t'appelles Naveau Bruno
muscuro Navo c'est un surnom c'est pour
ça que ça quand les gens disent je
t'appelle Bruno n'avoue comme tu veux
pour moi c'est comme Seb et Sébastien ok
parce que Navo c'est un surnom
que j'ai depuis l'adolescence avec mes
potes d'adolescence donc iron ce qu'on
se connaît depuis qu'on est tout petit
on parlait une espèce de langue secrète
mais pas du tout secrète et un faux
javanais beaucoup plus simple je te
rappelle toi tu as du connaître la
langue de gueule des feux et dégueu de
feu langue de Gueux nous c'était la
langue d'âge et donc et d'ailleurs elle
existe un peu il y a deux trois mots tu
vois je passais toujours entendu qu'a vu
pour dire un cul non voilà ou un plat
vent pour un plan non plus c'est la
langue Dav c'est tu mets have au milieu
de la dernière syllabe ok d'accord Bruno
ça faisait brune à veau c'est devenu
Navo là tu parles les deux Kyron et
justement toi tu as été co-auteur en
humour de kheiron de Kyan kojanditch
Charlie Souagnon de Greg Romano de
Thomas VDB tété auteur de Sébastian Marx
de Sébastian Marx c'est vrai ouais ça je
savais pas de Ambroise et Xavier
actuellement ok c'est super ce qu'ils
font et quand est-ce que tu avais
commencé à coécrire pour les autres la
première fois tu sais ou pas mais j'ai
commencé en coécrivant en fait j'ai
commencé le métier en
8 on va dire comment c'est le métier
sérieusement quoi je veux que ce soit
mon travail et j'étais co-auteur de
Keyron c'est comme ça même que je suis
rentré dans le truc c'est quelqu'un qui
m'a appelé il m'a même pas vraiment
appelé il m'appelait parce que c'est un
pote d'enfance et à force que je lui
dise ah tu pourrais faire site tu
pourrais faire ça parce que lui il
arrivait au Jamel Comédie Club ok il m'a
dit non mais il vient directement tu
t'es jamais projeté en colère et très
vite une partie de ton métier ou ton
métier ça a été d'écrire des blagues bah
je me suis toujours projeté en auteur
quoi est-ce que tu considères que tu
écris des blagues ou que tu écris pour
quelqu'un quelque chose parce que moi je
t'ai vu travailler des fois tu lances
juste des idées que tu tires un peu dans
tous les sens sans formaliser une vanne
au sens littéral tu vois est-ce que tu
écris des vannes ou est-ce que tu écris
un univers en vrai si demain toi et moi
on se met à écrire tu dis ouais je veux
je te prends comme co-auteur viens on
écrit un truc on va pas chercher des
blagues ouais on va se promener on va
discuter on va exactement les blagues il
y a un côté les blagues on les trouvera
ce qui est important c'est le thème
l'angle surtout l'axe tu vois donc en
vrai je vais dire écoute Fabien on
connaissent on se connaît vraiment donc
c'est quoi déjà pendant deux mois on va
traîner ensemble on va boire des coups
on va prendre des cafés et tu vas me
raconter toute ta vie et surtout pas
forcément
imaginons que toi tu dis mais j'ai
aucune envie de parler de mon enfance
mais juste raconte moi toute ta life et
surtout comment tu vois le monde parce
qu'à partir de là on va c'est comme si
ça me ressemble pour un moment te dire
tu pourrais faire ça on pourrait dire ça
tu pourrais dire ça et que j'aime bien
c'est capter la
capter la personne tu vois du coup tu es
Mentalist ouais ou si je sais pas
qu'est-ce que le mentalisme
tu peux pas faire arriver tu as jamais
posé
attends mentalisme j'ai l'impression que
c'est intéressant parce que ça échappe
un peu à l'autre tu vois en tout cas
dans l'exercice du mentalisme c'est
acheter mentalisé il y a un truc de
ouais plus dans le fantasme mais en tout
cas oui tes fins psychologue l'idée
c'est de comprendre l'autre je vais
intéresser en fait peut-être interviewer
ou biographe je sais pas un truc comme
ça en fait ça m'intéresse réellement je
pense que j'ai trouvé l'endroit où en
vrai je le fais pour des gens qui sont
pas humoristes et qui montrent jamais
sur scène ça m'intéresse pas forcément
toute ta bio mais la manière que tu as
de voir les choses et de te dire non
mais pourquoi tu vois il y a à force de
pourquoi un peu comme un enfant tu vois
s'il me demande trop souvent pourquoi à
un moment tu te mets raisonné sur
qu'est-ce que l'univers il y a un peu ce
truc là quoi plus on va discuter mieux
je vais te connaître
et mieux je vais te connaître mieux je
vais écrire pour toi et surtout avec toi
tu as été aussi créateur pour des séries
bloquer Serge Le mytho bref bref c'est
devenu un genre à part entière c'est
devenu vraiment une manière de faire moi
je me suis inquiète les premiers
épisodes que je vois je sais pas combien
il y avait de plans à la minute c'est
pas si tu as beaucoup une centaine à la
minute c'était vraiment et je pense pas
exagérant en disant une certaine à la
minute quoi c'était fou tout ça fontaine
à la minute bon et si tu comptes les ce
qu'on appelle les Flex ouais parce que
sinon une centaine à la minute ça me
fait plus d'un par seconde ça je parle
vraiment le nombre de plans affichés à
l'écran peu importe leur durée quoi tu
vois oui c'est possible donc ma première
question c'est est-ce que tu es au
courant que peut-être j'ai pété va voler
ton travail et quand tu veux on va
rentrer dans un grand débat sur le chat
GPT parce que chat GPT je suis pas sûr
que ce sera chat GPT je pense que ce
sera GPT ou un autre équivalent de GPT
là on rentre dans un truc technique avec
des fineschungs différents parce que
chat j'ai se content d'être
conversationnel alors il peut c'est le
plus connu de en gros tu je sais pas si
tu vois mais j'ai pété c'est le voilà
c'est l'intelligence artificielle
derrière les chats c'est une version de
GPT qui a été un module conversationnel
ou en gros ils ont modifié certains
paramètres pour que ça devienne quelque
chose de conversationnel je pense qu'en
fait on a on voit une évolution qui est
assez folle mais je pense que les c'est
toujours pareil je pense que c'est les
10 derniers pour cent pour que le truc
devienne fou qui vont prendre beaucoup
plus de temps que ce qu'on croit c'est
que passer de ces nul et ça ressemble au
chatbot de base sur les sites de SAV là
qui comprennent rien même Siri qui est
pas dingue à chat GPT cette évolution on
se dit [__] là il a pris
un million de points il est passé à 9000
tête à ton truc de Végéta et tu vois son
potentiel et en fait je pense que les
derniers steps vont être un peu plus dur
à atteindre par contre le fait qu'ils
croise autant de données c'est quand
même beaucoup beaucoup la définition de
la créativité mais je pense que ça va
être un très très bon assistant jusqu'à
ce qu'il puisse vraiment remplacer les
gens parce qu'il va faire des choses
très créatives parce que ça créativité
ça consiste à mélanger des trucs et tu
n'avais pas prévu de mélanger quoi j'ai
essayé c'était la version 3 j'ai essayé
de je me suis dit je vais me mettre en
da avec un bon prompt peut-être ou en
disant écoute on est en train de faire
un brainstorm tu es humoriste je vais
donner un peu les caractéristiques
propose-moi des thèmes sur ça doit être
la réforme des retraites et dans et dans
les propositions et être trop bizarre
puis un moment il me dit la réforme des
retraites c'est comme
il fait une comparaison il comprend tu
sens qu'il dit ok stand-up c'est comme
la réforme des retraites c'est comme
jouer je sais plus quel jeu c'était avec
Emmanuel Macron déjà celle-là elle est
pas mal et en fait je me mets comme si
je l'encourage à lui les juniors moi je
suis senior tu vois ah c'est pas mal
vas-y creuse là-dessus et après à partir
d'un moment il arrivait plus à creuser
tu vois mais il comprenait sans
comprendre mais je disais oublie les
c'est comme c'est comme c'est trop
classique donc il remplaçait le SECOM
par autre chose ce que font les scènes
de peur c'est intéressant ce que je l'ai
vu évoluer genre au début il avait 01 de
stand-up puis un moment il avait genre
deux ans quand tu arrêtes de faire
l'essai comme ok tu vois ce que tu dis
ah c'est comme ça sonne trop comme vous
avez remarqué dis pas que vous avez
remarqué d'y passer comme ok il arrivait
à formuler autrement mais il avait pas
tu sens que ça reste un programme qui ne
fait que compléter des phrases mais du
coup tu pourras peut-être coacher dans
le temps il n'y a pour qu'elle devienne
rôle l'abrégation c'est est-ce que
vraiment il n'y a peut sortir vraiment
des choses drôles et surprenants je
pense mais c'est ce qu'on appelle le
fight tunes je me dis bah à un moment si
tu lui mets que du stand en gros tu lui
dis c'est ça tu lui apprends cette
manière de parler en fait tu lui dis
maintenant tu as brassé le monde entier
pour savoir construire des phrases mais
tu vas prioriser ce type de Moodle ce
corpus là et le corpus tu mets vraiment
toutes les blagues et tous les stand-up
et tous les humours que tout l'humour
qui a existé depuis la nuit des temps et
tu dis c'est ça ta priorité je pense
qu'il peut comprendre sans comprendre
les nettoyer il peut structurer une
phrase et tu dis ça va pas être grave
que l'intelligence artificielle fasse
90%, 95%, 99% de déchets parce que on a
aussi à côté de ça des algorithmes qui
vont faire le prix qui vont faire le tri
en fait c'est ça et tu vois je veux dire
c'est moi là j'ai une intelligence
artificielle et que je veux faire une
bonne blague je vais la mettre sur
Reddit parce que les gens vont voter
pour la bonne et puis elle va monter
naturellement voilà tu dis bah c'est
celle-là la bonne blague si tu fais ça
un milliard de fois un moment tu peux
avoir 32 blagues ça te fait un passage
un bon passage dans un quart d'heure
mais à force de le dompter il va
comprendre c'est sûr on n'est pas très
loin dehors je pense avant que tu fasses
bref tu écris pour plein d'humoristes on
en parlait tout à l'heure donc iron et
j'ai appris qu'avant vous faisiez du rap
ensemble à l'époque tu avais déjà quand
même un petit truc vis-à-vis de l'humour
ou pour toi ta vie ce serait le rap en
fait on faisait les deux mais je pense
que là on parle d'une époque moi j'ai
jamais été moteur je suis pas du tout un
moteur moi je suis un gros suiveur c'est
pour ça que quand tu me dis qu'est-ce
que tu as fait dans la vie c'est très
rare de voir un truc que j'ai fait tout
seul
première classe bah en tout cas c'est
moi j'ai pas la motive moi mon but dans
la vie c'est d'être chez moi et de rien
faire et donc les c'est les autres qui
me motivent la motivation des autres ça
me booste et Keyron lui par contre il a
toujours été motivé et ça avait pas mal
décollé justement sous son impulsion
beaucoup son impulsion à lui quoi ça
marchait plutôt bien ce qu'on s'était
vraiment investi dans le truc on avait
fait une mixte à l'époque fallait faire
des mixtapes de featuring et il y en
avait quand même des gros non tu vois on
s'était retrouvé ce que je vois comment
écrire
mener le truc il sait donner envie on
avait des snipers des 3e oeils Fonky
Family c'est fou maintenant il y en a
c'est des stars incroyables moi je me
posais je me poser rarement la question
de l'objectif du truc je me pose la
question de ce que je suis content de le
faire là maintenant et je laisse l'autre
fixer un objectif à ce machin tu vois
parce qu'en fait c'est ça quand tu crées
tu as le plaisir de créer et il y a
rendre ce que tu as créé visible ou
disponible pour les autres ou réel quoi
tu vois toi c'est pas la partie qui te
passionne le plus ouais en fait elle
peut me passionner si elle te passionne
si tu dis bon maintenant il faut
absolument regarde j'ai eu cette idée
pour le mettre en avant chez ah ou alors
on pourrait faire ça on pourrait faire
ça mais moi je vais pas arriver en
disant j'ai une idée pour mettre quelque
chose en avant ça c'est vraiment ceux
avec qui
je travaille qui font ça mais alors du
coup ton propre spectacle ben il a très
peu de chance de voir le jour parce que
il faudrait pour ça que je m'automotive
et si j'ai le choix entre regarder
une série ou écrament spectacle je
préfère regarder une série alors que moi
j'étais écouté sur on a fait les
plateaux ensemble genre la nouvelle
scène ou des trucs comme ça au numéro de
marché très très bien c'est pas quand tu
reçois l'accueil du public de ton numéro
solo que tu as écrit que pour toi et que
tu fais tout seul ça te nourrit pas
assez pour te dire ok j'emmène ça plus
loin ouais bon ça me fait plaisir mais
ça me fait tout autant plaisir si c'est
si on écrit ensemble et que c'est toi
qui monte ça me booste pas plus que ça
en tout cas l'équilibre tu vois là quand
je dis ah c'est cool en ce moment il y a
Sébastian Marx Thomas dB et Ambroise et
Xavier qui sont sur scène je me dis bah
c'est trop cool parce que là j'ai un peu
fini même si c'est jamais fini de temps
on se revoit on refait un point on
modifie deux trois trucs mais il y a ce
truc de c'est fini mais le truc existe
maintenant il est en train de vivre moi
j'aurais la flemme de le faire 300 fois
tu vois je pense que tu vois il y a ce
truc où pas la flemme mais facile à
flemme en vrai si je pense que j'aurais
la flemme parce que ça m'a jamais
vraiment motivé moi j'ai vu ton oeil
on était à Lausanne c'était pour les
trois ans du lit 2 Comedy Club et Kian
fait son passage et je regardais pas Ken
je te regardais toi en train de regarder
Kian et je trouvais ça fou il y avait à
sentiment de déjà comme si tu découvrais
le texte ça c'était fou pour moi de
fierté
et tout j'ai l'impression que tu le
vivais comme si c'était toi enfin tu
vois il y avait pas de trucs de je suis
dans l'ombre et merde tu vois c'est lui
qui porte la lumière du bébé qu'on a
écrit quoi tu vois et cette fois là je
m'étais dit ok donc un vrai coeur c'est
quelqu'un qui qui se nourrit de voir
aussi juste la chose aboutir et porter
par quelqu'un d'autre quoi bah ouais
ouais mais en fait il y a aucune en fait
c'est intéressant parce que souvent les
gens qui mentent sont des gens qui vont
sur scène et donc eux ils ont un attrait
ils ont une envie ils aiment être sur
scène être avec le public etc donc pour
eux ça leur paraît être un
comment dire limite une qualité mais en
fait oui en soi c'est tout autant une
qualité d'émettre sur scène que de s'en
[__] d'être sur scène faisait mais
c'est pas du tout un effort en rien
c'est juste ce qui est intéressant c'est
ça c'est de dire où est ma place ça me
fait sincèrement rien et c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs parce que c'est
une question qui revient beaucoup alors
c'est pas trop dur d'être dans le nom et
ça je si on en avait pas parlé je me
serais pas posé la question parce que
pour moi il y a un truc où c'est un
projet la personne sur scène est un
projet comme un autre tu vois quand on
fait brève c'est pareil on voit pas
l'image mais c'est un projet et ça
paraît pas du tout on dirait rarement un
Real
tu vois tu vas pas voir un avis US en
disant alors tu as le seum un peu tu
aimerais pas trop être de gens du jardin
et être dans des artistes mais c'est moi
qui l'ai fait c'est-à-dire c'est super
non il y a un truc de mais c'est pour la
scène il y a un truc différent je peux
peut-être parce qu'il y a une
gratification instantanée il y a un truc
des applaudissements et tout de cette
sensation de pauvre c'est pas lui qu'on
applaudit mais techniquement ce que ce
que les gens applaudissent c'est là
c'est l'ensemble tu vois d'ailleurs
c'est bien quand l'artiste
pas dans le piège de croire que c'est
lui en tant que personne qu'on applaudit
est-ce que c'est là que tu montes en
l'air et que tu non cesseras toujours
ton oeuvre qu'on a pas dit c'est ce que
tu montes de toi sur scène Tian il a dit
que tu as un an de moins que lui mais
que tu as 10 ans de plus dans ta tête
c'est parce qu'il est gentil ça dépend
ce qui veut dire par là c'est un
compliment tu crois oui
d'essayer de trouver ah il a voulu dire
une vacherie il en dit pas il a pas du
tout comme ça quand vous avez eu l'idée
de la série de bref c'était en mode on
s'accompte des vannes sans savoir qu'une
idée de malade va arriver ou alors vous
étiez vraiment en recherche d'une idée
de série alors on a fait le truc après
par contre quand on moi je me souviens
que ça me le truc me chauffait ok tu as
mis comme souvent
j'ai vu quelque chose non c'est en
vérité il y a 4 5 autres trucs je pense
dans la même période où j'étais là mais
ça aussi c'est j'en mets par contre
quand on l'a quand on a fait le pilote
je me souviens que Ken était un peu mal
à l'aise parce que j'arrêtais pas de
dire mais ça c'est chiant mais en fait
j'étais tellement content je voy ais un
truc que j'avais envie de voir vraiment
et je trouvais que c'était bien fait et
qu'il y avait un truc un peu de waouh
regarde l'équipe toute l'équipe a bien
fait sa partition
c'est en train de se épicer la première
fois vous étiez en train de créer de la
vidéo ensemble ouais ok après can nuit
il faisait sur France 4 il faisait un
truc qui s'appelle festival de Kyan et
il avait déjà fait moi j'avais fait un
programme pour Dailymotion je pense à
l'époque non juste non gratos et on
verra bien on le met avec Iron qui
s'appelle les voisins du dessus qui
était ma première expérience de
réalisation et donc là c'était la
première fois que le tien et moi on
faisait un truc et c'est surtout en fait
il y avait il y a eu une espèce de
d'alignement de on avait les bonnes
personnes les bons comédiens qu'on
connaissait parce que c'était des
humoristes qui étaient avec nous on
avait le bon chef up parce qu'il avait
déjà bossé sur un truc le bon monteur le
bon il y avait ce truc cette sensation
de eh on a
il y a plus qu'à tous les éléments la
fine équipe est réunie donc toi en temps
réel quand tu voyais le projet naître tu
disais en tout cas c'est exactement ce
qu'on avait en tête
je crois que c'est parce qu'on appelait
Harry pendant le montage et que je
disais à Harry ça tue et qui a gagné
moi franchement je pense que c'est
vraiment bien mais dans ma tête ça
voulait pas dire ça va être un hit ou
les gens vont aimer juste là franchement
c'est trop bien ça c'est le genre de
truc et si les gens aiment pas pour moi
j'ai rien fait de mal je me dis pas à
mince pourquoi surtout ça ressemblait à
ce que c'était même mieux que ce qu'on
imaginait quand on l'écrit tu vois parce
qu'il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup de
réflexion au moment du montage
typiquement le avec toutes les images on
l'a trouvé au montage je me suis en
testé plein de trucs avec le monteur
Valentin
légendaire dans bref quoi c'est le
monteur de bref et on testait plein de
trucs tu vois on a passé une semaine on
a dit vas-y mets les images à l'envers
mais les images à l'endroit mais là on
accéléré mais coupe un truc mais un
machin tu vois et c'était vraiment un
laboratoire où il y avait encore plein
de choses à faire
au moment du montage quoi et même à
l'écriture parce que tu parles
d'écriture vous aviez écrit 32 épisodes
en 15 jours en fait ce qu'on a fait
c'est qu'on a écrit un épisode et on l'a
montré à Harry le script et on a vite
compris Harry à mais il faut le piloter
ça parce que en fait ça paraît évident
maintenant si je te dis tiens c'est un
épisode du bref lis le tu sais ce que
c'est mais sinon tu vois il m'a regardé
je l'ai regardé il m'agresse quoi votre
truc là déjà ça dure 20 minutes parce
que c'est le script est hyper gros tu
fais non non ça dure une minute trente
maintenant regarde je passe
pour savoir à peu près combien de temps
dure ton truc on avait vraiment un
nombre de pages parce que c'était
vraiment mais là il regarde ton jour
c'est tu vois c'est il m'a dit c'est
quand trois
décors machin parle bonjour C'est quand
ce 4 maintenant donc ça prend donc on en
a écrit un on l'a piloté on l'a montré
c'est Harry qui avait une entrée chez
Canal pour un autre projet qui est avec
son iPad addition j'ai ça on aime bien
ils nous ont convoqué starrielle Sarah
quoi la directrice est probable qui nous
a dit est-ce que vous pouvez m'en écrire
4 pour voir à quoi ça ressemblerait
c'est une série est-ce que en gros
c'était est-ce que vous pouvez en faire
plein ce que vous seriez capable d'en
faire sans ce à quoi j'ai dit oui je
sais que Kian était un peu genre
il m'a dit mais non mais attends mais on
a mis un mois à faire le 1 ouais mais
c'est le moment de dire oui de toute
façon tu vois pas dire non on va pas
dire non désolé
on rentre chez nous on avait une bonne
idée mais one shot et elle a dit ce que
pouvait en écrire quatre autres pour
voir à quoi ça ressemblerait maintenant
que j'ai vu à quoi ressemble le format
on en a écrit 4 c'était en mai et ce qui
s'est passé c'est que c'est on était
vraiment en pleine de l'ancienne
frustration frustration qui existe
toujours mais là on était vraiment en
train de se remettre de cette
frustration de à chaque fois on dit que
c'est bon ah oui et au dernier moment ça
se fait pas et on avait dit à Harry on
écrit rien tant que dis-nous c'est quoi
symbolique c'est quoi le truc qui veut
dire c'est bon là moi je me souviens
vraiment qu'avec Ken en plus il revenait
d'une période où il était pas très bien
on se met à écrire comme des oufs et
qu'on nous dit ouais non en fait arrêtez
de rêver vous ferez jamais canal bon
vraiment on va pas s'en mettre ces
rouleaux on va changer de travail donc
dis-nous c'est quoi le truc a priori
c'est le visage pas quoi c'est quand le
boss a mis un coup de tampon pour dire
de façon l'argent il part et ben tu nous
dis quand on a le visa et le visa on l'a
eu début juillet sauf que à partir de là
c'était ouais mais c'est diffusé fin
août c'est ça ça sortait fin août donc
c'est pour ça que en vrai on a écrit
ouais c'est ça
ce que j'ai c'était 5 32 en 15 jours
ouais 30 vu qu'on en avait fait 4 quand
les uns un peu modifié qu'il y en avait
un ça fait 5 ça fait 35 mais il y en a
un qui était pas écrit qui était le
baiser bon en tout cas une trentaine en
15 jours donc c'est-à-dire quand toi tu
passes de j'écris des stand up avec des
gars avec qui je traîne pendant deux
mois pour savoir ce qu'ils ont dans leur
tête pour comprendre leur vision du
monde et comme ça après en discutant
avec eux j'oriente l'écriture je dois
prendre 30 et quelques épisodes en deux
semaines
comment comment déjà toi tu la prends
dans mentalement est-ce que ça te fait
faire un cauchemar où tu te dis ok de
challenge et comment tu t'organises
est-ce que tu as un process de travail
pour le faire parce que vous ne pouvez
pas échouer entre guillemets quoi c'est
sûr que dans 15 jours faut que ce soit
après là tu peux pas dire attends j'y
réfléchis demain quoi bah alors déjà le
côté de moi etc ça faisait un moment que
en fait on écrivait le spectacle de
Cannes ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'à
l'époque qui elle m'a dit ah j'aime bien
comment t'écris on n'arrêtait pas de
s'échanger des blagues des machins et il
m'a dit ah tu veux pas m'aider pour
faire le mon nouveau spectacle donc
c'est pendant qu'on était en train
d'écrire son nouveau spectacle qu'on a
eu l'idée de bref quand même c'est lui
qui a dit elle serait bien de faire ça
je crois carrément on vient on le fait
on a fait une pause quoi ce qui nous a
un peu
dévié du chemin qui était en fin
spectacle et on y va il y a une pause
bref pour ça que pulsion arrive bien
après donc ce truc de deux mois c'était
déjà fait on se connaissait bien avec
Yann et on savait qu'on écrivait bien
ensemble et que ça fonctionnait on
voyait à peu près la même chose dans le
format et on était sur Aix en fait donc
il y avait ce truc je refuserai là comme
dites à 15 jours pour écrire 35 épisodes
de Bref j'ai bien c'est pas possible
mais la façon on n'avait pas le choix et
il y avait cette énergie de dire bon
allez ça en fait de par jour donc c'est
quoi on fait que ça pendant pendant 15
jours on a essayé une espèce de barre de
chargement quoi ok on écrit le
pourcentage de travail accompli et ce
qu'on a décidé de faire pour pas mourir
créativement c'est d'être très créatif
au début et très administratif à la fin
parce que finalement on a un peu gardé
même maintenant c'est un peu notre
méthode quand je dis d'abord on discute
on trouvera les blagues à la fin dans le
cas de brève qu'on avait que 15 jours on
s'est dit d'abord on trouve toutes les
idées ce qu'on a appelé la chambre et
les jouets
ça veut dire que d'abord vient on fait
les chambres et les jouets ça veut dire
si j'ai une idée de thème d'épisodes ce
serait une chambre et on dit il peut y
avoir cette chambre là il peut y avoir
un moment il dit un moment où il
recroise la meuf et un moment et dès
qu'on a une autre idée
une façon de dire les choses une blague
une tournure une situation c'est un
jouet ce qui fait qu'à mi-chem on a une
liste de jouets une liste de chambres
donc techniquement c'est un peu
l'équivalent du document blague en vrac
et l'équivalent de thèmes possibles et
après tu dois mettre les jouets dans les
chambres et en fait à un moment tu as
des jouets dans des chambres qui sont
des épisodes et tu as plus qu'à rentrer
dans la chambre et à rendre ça cohérence
et ça c'est l'administratif et ça c'est
le côté plus administratif même si en
vrai il y a un une partie créative à ce
moment-là mais elle est moins les moins
frustrante parce que tu
te demandes comment j'arrive de cette
idée que je trouve bonne à cette autre
idée que je trouve bonne et que ce soit
cohérent dans l'épisode tu es motivé
quoi de dire je vais juste construire un
peu des ponts et des fois en faisant un
pont tu fais il est super ce pont en
fait c'est une nouvelle idée qui nous
amène un autre endroit mais tu te
mettais pas fatigué alors que si on
avait fait dans l'ordre on devrait aller
épisode 1 tu serais épuisé au fur et il
y aura une espèce de baisse de
créativité de motivation de l'épisode 30
à l'épisode 40 moi ça me rappelle les
rappeurs comme quoi ton passé de rappeur
c'est qui qui sont leurs thèmes et qui
écrivent des punch ouais qui se mettent
dans un cahier ou dans une note sur le
téléphone et puis après quand ils
doivent écrire un morceau ils disent ah
[__] cette phrase là elle claquée
cette phrase là
on avait parlé avec Aurel et d'ailleurs
c'est il a fait la même chose quand on a
fait bloquer ah ouais il a sorti on a vu
le même truc de ben on sort nos carnet
tu vois et lui il a le même carnet sauf
que lui c'est des trucs qui voulaient
mettre dans des morceaux et nous c'est
des trucs qu'on met quelque part
qu'est-ce que ça t'a fait de réaliser
aussi parce que bref tu co-réalisé je
dis pas de bêtises on écrivait à deux on
les aide c'était important pour toi de
coaliser en fait c'est important pour
nous de réaliser parce que encore plus
dans le cas de bref mais en général tu
vois c'est quand même mieux de soit tu
as ton Réal qui est exactement dans ta
team depuis le jour 1 genre Jonathan
barré avec le Palmashow et tu sais que
vous avez la même idée que vous allez
faire le même truc soit la base c'était
juste auteur ce qui était notre cas Ken
et moi et on s'est vite rendu compte que
ça pouvait il y avait tellement de
choses à apporter au moment de réaliser
puis aussi au montage etc qui est quand
même le montage c'est pas les auteurs
qui viennent sur le montage c'est le
réalisateur qui vient superviser le
montage qu'on s'est rendu compte qu'il
fallait réaliser
notre truc mais c'est pour ça que
souvent je dis je suis auteur alors
qu'en vrai je suis réalisateur
techniquement j'ai réalisé bref bloqué
Serge Le mytho mais parce que
je suis devenu réalisateur parce que je
voulais pas confier le bébé trop tôt à
quelqu'un d'autre qui va les lever
différemment de ce que j'imaginais après
il revient il y a une moustache et je
suis là mais c'est pas du tout ce que je
voulais faire moi quelle est cette
enfant
c'est intéressant d'être vraiment du
début jusqu'à la fin de la chaîne
3 ans trois saisons vous faites en fait
c'est pas trois saisons c'est trois
sessions mais en fait c'est bizarre
trois session parce qu'en réalité c'est
une saison il y a qu'une saison bref ça
dure un an ça dure un an ça commence le
29 août ça finit le fin juin de l'année
d'après donc c'est vraiment un an sur au
Grand Journal en vérité bref ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'il y a eu trois
sessions de tournage dont une de deux
épisodes donc en vrai c'est deux
sessions et après mais comme on a sorti
en 2 DVD comme il y a plein de gens qui
pensent que c'est deux saisons ça
pourrait être deux mini-saison quoi mais
en vrai nous on s'est toujours dit c'est
une saison et c'est c'est là ma question
c'est dès le départ ou en tout cas très
tôt vous dites une fois cette histoire
là est terminée ça s'appelle fin et nous
on fait autre chose dans notre vie quoi
non je pense qu'on a décidé ça
on s'est dit de façon faux on veut
boucler un peu notre truc mais on l'a
décidé c'est pour ça qu'il y a de il y a
une session de deux épisodes c'est parce
qu'on a dit on peut remettre le chapeau
final on la conclusion parce qu'en fait
on arrête ok donc mais je saurai pas
dire exactement quand est-ce qu'on s'est
dit viens on arrête et pourquoi vous
dites ça parce que vous êtes c'est
vraiment vous avez arrêté alors en même
temps c'est la manière la plus classe
quoi c'est vraiment au top il y a rien à
reprocher c'est un succès et c'est là où
vous dites bon ben voilà ça c'est fait
bon
commencez à s'ennuyer ok enfin tu vois
fatigué et donc à dire on pourrait faire
ça mais c'est un peu facile on pourrait
faire ça et on s'est dit si on commence
à s'auto saouler on va saouler les gens
dans six mois c'est eux qui vont être
sous les sinon on est sous les
maintenant le temps de faire le truc etc
ils vont s'en rendre compte ils vont
être saouler autant arrêter
et voir ce qu'on fait derrière et pas ce
qui est devenu une bonne chose après
coup les gens étaient plutôt épatés
qu'on ait fait ça etc
un choix c'est une vraie rare financière
je pense pas
on fait ce single pour voir on fait le
single c'est de c'est un hit et dire
alors l'album on va pas le faire on va
faire autre chose on verra plaisir que
ça allait partir même je sais pas si
l'idée c'est présenté sur un long
métrage on a essayé ouais on s'est dit
on pourrait peut-être faire un film
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que ça se
termine avec en vrai le dernier épisode
de Bref il y a un truc caché en morse et
le truc caché en morse c'est le titre
qu'on imaginait pour le long-métrage si
on faisait un long métrage c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que Ken dit sa
dernière réplique c'est je te laisse
j'arrive au cinéma
et on s'est dit bien on le fait large
parce qu'on n'est pas sûr de nous soit
moi ça existe si on veut l'utiliser
arrive au cinéma ce qui est arrivé soit
c'est on va aussi faire des trucs pour
le cinéma ce qui est arrivé soit c'est
bref arrive au cinéma mais il n'est pas
bref j'arrive au cinéma tu vois et donc
nous dans notre tête le film ça plaît
bref oui ou non
et donc c'est pour ça à la fin si tu
décores le morse je crois que c'est du
morse à l'envers je puis on fait une
connerie c'est ça dit bref oui ou non
après on s'est posé on essaie de faire
le film et on n'était pas contents du
truc et donc on s'est dit ça serait
dommage d'avoir arrêté une série en se
disant faut pas faire n'importe quoi
pour faire un film ou on n'est pas sûr
de nous mais je pense qu'il y a un peu
ce truc un des grands des grandes
inspirations de bref c'est clapish avec
l'auberge espagnole et donc finalement
la trilogie qu'il a fait derrière c'est
que je crois pas du tout il me semble
même qu'il a déjà dit que l'auberge
espagnole il l'a pas fait en disant il y
aura une suite mais il avait ce même
rapport au notes des trucs dans un
carnet et puis au bout d'un moment il
avait des nouveaux trucs dans son carnet
et il s'est dit ah mais c'est nouveau
truc dans mon nouveau carnet ça peut
faire une suite de l'auberge espagnole
mais au bon moment le frais quand ça
vaut le coup de le faire parce que j'ai
des idées à défendre
c'est pour ça qu'on a déjà dit bref
c'est fini pour tout genre
quand on aura des bonnes idées et vu que
ça fait plus de 10 ans maintenant
comment ça avoir des trucs pas mal bref
oui c'est bref
après vous avez fait bloquer avec Yann
et gringe Serge demito et pour bloquer
je me souviens que sur les premiers
épisodes qui ont été diffusés il y avait
vous avez été accusé de sexisme pas des
militants de féministes est-ce que tu
t'en souviens et comment vous l'avez
vécu toi au départ ça comment vous
l'avez vécu toi
j'ai tendance à pas être d'accord avec
mes personnages ok genre très peu
d'accord sur cette que dans la vraie vie
mais tu vois il y a un peu cet effet si
tu réfléchis bien merci Simpson ou
même en dehors de l'humour à Walter
White même Michael Scott j'ai jamais de
la vie je veux être avec eux dans la vie
c'est les pires personnes mais dans la
mais tu les trouves marrants donc moi il
y avait un peu ce truc même le mec de
Bref même le héros de bref à la base
j'ai très peu d'accord avec lui tu vois
il m'a beaucoup où il est très lâche il
dit rien il pète des plombs il s'énerve
contre tout le monde il trompe sa meuf
il part et du coup il part en dépression
et donc dans le cas de aurait les grains
je m'y attendais d'ailleurs c'est même
ça s'est même plutôt bien passé pour un
gars qui a eu autant de scandale dès le
départ de sa vie sur un morceau et en
plus moi je savais moi j'avais poussé un
peu j'étais bon les gars on fait ça mais
ce serait bien de faire un morceau sur
le féminisme de faire un épisode sur le
féminisme se faire un épisode et des
trucs moi je disais bon je vois le type
de public qu'on va avoir c'est bien si
on met de trois sociétés en plus en
vérité c'était pas le bad boss de
l'année ce côté l'épisode s'appelle les
meufs et ils disent de la merde sur les
meufs c'est le con qui disent la merde
sur des meufs je l'ai pas spécialement
mal vécu je pense je suis celui qui avec
Orel peut-être qu'il a le moins mal vécu
ok ah je m'étais posé la question parce
que j'étais là quand tu sors d'un truc
ou
transgénérationnel où tout le monde dit
c'est bien c'est cool etc mais c'est pas
vous enfin c'est le cas mais pas tant
que ça je suis sur Twitter depuis le
jour 1 et depuis le jour 1 sur Twitter
quand je fais quelque chose j'écoute
attentivement en plus alors que c'est
dur parce que tout le monde t'insulte
enfin les gens sont très énervés mais
c'est intéressant ce que les gens vont
dire et ça m'a fait réfléchir d'ailleurs
sur le côté ce que je te dis là ce que
je te dis là je l'ai pas sorti de mon
chapeau je me suis rendu compte en
disant ah oui j'ai pas tu vois que je
prenais d'exemple de Michael Scott ou de
il y a quelqu'un il y a Jim quand il dit
un truc sexy Michael Scott il y a jean
qui fait ouais c'est ça nous on n'a pas
le gars qui fait tu vois parce qu'en
gros ce que les gens vivent mal c'est la
manière dont on te le dit surtout sur
Twitter sachant qu'en plus Twitter c'est
pas une personne qui te le dit mal et tu
le dises toutes mais c'est qu'elle le
dise tout en même temps avec plus ou
moins de de façon plus ou moins énervée
et puis plus court possible donc au plus
violent possible voilà tu as la
sensation qu'il y a vraiment 1000
personnes en même temps qui te crie
dessus donc je comprends que la réaction
soit de faire mais en vrai j'ai tendance
peut-être que c'est parce que je suis
bien câblé là-dessus à dire c'est pas
grave allez tout le monde est en train
de crier mais il y a quelque chose il
écrit pas pour rien ces gens c'est pas
possible pourquoi il crie soit ils ont
complètement en même temps et c'est
incroyable soit j'ai une leçon à en
tirer mais c'est compliqué parce que
bloquer c'était bloqué et que peu
importe qu'on allait nous dire je n'ai
pas dire ok vous savez quoi j'ai bien
réfléchi et en fait maintenant ils vont
avoir que des propos hyper voilà mais
j'ai essayé d'installer des trucs moi
j'étais content je savais qu'il y a une
épisode féminisme qui est sorti ou ce
qui était intéressant c'était de dire
comment deux cons parle de féminisme que
j'aimais bien c'était qu'il y a toute la
phase sur le l'avortement ou il dit ça
me regarde pas je trouvais que c'était
l'argument important les gars de base
qui s'en foutent qui regardent ils sont
en train de regarder un autre gars comme
eux qui s'en fout dire un truc de façon
un peu rigolote en faisant qu'en fait
une meuf elle peut me payer un resto
c'est la plus d'argent que moi c'est
cool c'est bon parti pris c'est est-ce
qu'il vaut mieux convaincre un petit peu
essayer de mettre des graines chez des
gens qui s'en foutent ou satisfaire des
militants qui sont déjà au courant
pendant que tu écris tout ça en même
temps tu continues à écrire pour la
scène pour Greg Romano pour Charleroi tu
as pas eu envie d'arrêter d'écrire pour
les spectacles vivants genre les deux te
nourrissent différemment ou je te pose
une question que tu t'es même pas posé
tellement la question elle se pose pas
ouais dans la question se pose pas trop
il y a que la question de l'emploi du
temps qui se pose en fait au moment de
bref jusqu'en 2012-2013 ça devenait très
compliqué
tu vois de tenir les deux trucs en même
temps parce que après bref il y a eu
beaucoup de trucs à gérer on voulait
tous maîtriser donc il y a ce truc de on
va faire un bouquin ok mais le bouquin
on va valider tout on veut faire un DVD
ok mais on va se taper pour que le DVD
soit au bon prix au bon endroit au
moment avec la bonne jaquette ça nous a
pris pas mal de temps je prends jusqu'en
2000 en 2013 en fait moi j'ai aucun
problème de temps j'ai beaucoup plus de
trucs auxquels j'ai envie de dire oui
que de temps surtout que dans le temps
je compte le fait que j'aime bien rien
branler qui ne prend pas mal de tête
c'est ça c'est quoi tes projets actuels
là il y a pas mal de là on va reprendre
normalement un bon moment mais je sais
pas exactement quand je sais pas si ça
la rentrée ou un petit peu avant le
podcast avec Yann Antoine soit qui
marche bien aussi Antoine soit c'est
cool
c'est marrant à faire
c'est cool on voit les gens sous un
autre un autre angle je sais pas il y a
un truc c'est vraiment rigolo en plus je
trouve que Kian c'est vraiment le là ça
marche très bien la bonne personne pour
présenter ce truc là moi je file juste
un coup de main sur les questions les
petits happing si on a puis les
spectacles qui tournent pour un mec qui
fait rien c'est pas mal je trouve qu'il
y a beaucoup de procrastinateurs et
procrastinatrice qui disent moi ma
passion c'est rien branler mais où je
vois la liste des choses qu'ils ont
réalisé qui est toujours un peu
impressionnante ouais mais parce que ça
se cumule aussi tu vois c'est aussi ça
là je pense là ça fait 15 ans donc tu
dis ouais c'est ouf il a fait au moins
15 trucs tu vois ça fait un par un moi
je pense qu'il est bon progrès
signataires c'est qu'ils savent
justement aller vite et loin dans les
trucs pour aussi se débarrasser des
côtés un peu chiants ou qu'ils ont
appris à trouver en fait l'appui tu vois
la petite potion magique qui fait que
toi la potion magique c'est se dire très
tôt en fait c'est pas moi qui vais être
à l'initiative des projets en fait juste
je vais me coller aux bonnes personnes
et mon talent ça va être de vraiment
toujours bien vérifier que c'est les
bonnes personnes
oui c'est parce que ça c'est le truc
numéro 1 c'est fait tes devoirs le
dimanche c'est parce que tu es obligé
d'aller à l'école moi dès l'instant on
m'a dit tu es plus moi j'ai arrêté
l'école à 16 ans parce que dès qu'on m'a
dit tu peux arrêter l'école ah bon j'en
sais plus obligé j'arrête alors si tu
veux que je te dise aucune envie d'y
aller je la tous les matins c'est une
torture je peux pas y aller moi et donc
il y a ce truc où tu te crées les bonnes
obligations c'est ça tu vois je sais pas
si on regardera toute cette femme mais
moi j'ai bien aimé la fin bah écoute moi
j'ai tout aimé garderai cette phrase et
sera le titre sur la vignette
merci beaucoup annabou d'avoir pris le
temps de cette interview à la table avec
nous je vous mets ces réseaux dans la
description comme d'habitude mais ouais
c'était passionnant je crois que on
aurait pu faire une interview de 3-4
heures avec grand plaisir avec lui merci
à vous de suivre toutes les vidéos sur
la chaîne d'être abonné n'oubliez pas du
coup le nouveau livre qui est sorti un
peu dans le mood de votre temps est
infini ça se complète en tout cas c'est
vraiment un peu plus sur la philosophie
du temps et de comment on fait pour les
processus cognitifs qui vont te
permettre de de réaliser un truc que tu
as envie de faire en fait vous avez tout
ça chez votre libraire et le lien dans
la description à très bientôt Ciao